As with all architectural styles, there are benefits and costs.
The benefits of the Layered Implicit Invocation architecture include im,
improved reusability.
Because the lower level components do not depend upon the upper
level components, you can use them in other situations.
So you can imagine taking.
Our handler for the resized window and using that in other applications as well.
There's also reduced complexity, because the, there are fewer the,
the actual components know less about each other and everything is implicit but
the complexity of the system can be reduced.
Making it easier to understand and maintain.
The, there is a cost, however.
The cost is slightly increased overhead,
that is performance overhead because of the extra levels of indirection.
Whenever you have an indirection, okay, that means that there's a two-steps in,
in resolving that.
You make the call, and then, the call has to be.
There has to be a call back and so on.
For phase 2 after we have selected the style, we will assign the components to
layers, determining the dependencies between the layers, and update the OCL.
In particular we will insure that each constraint,
is an equality with a single variable on the left hand side.